welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer theory
analysis of algorithms
so choosing the right algorithm can make
a big difference when you're programming
and in fact it can make the difference
between having a program that runs in a
reasonable amount of time
and a program that takes too long to run
for
reasonable size data sets so for small
data
sets you know there's a lot of different
algorithms that will work but
when you start working with large
amounts of uh data
more and more the particular algorithm
that you're using is going to make a
huge difference in whether or not you're
actually able to
analyze the data in a reasonable amount
of time or it's just going to take
long enough that for all practical
purposes you can't do it
in this lecture we're going to start by
taking a look at how to look for an item
in a collection
and we'll compare some different ways of
doing this and then after we've done
that we're going to take a
little bit of a look at how computer
scientists
go about uh comparing different
algorithms from a theoretical standpoint
all right so here i've got a list of
different sovereigns
uh of england and the simplest way i can
go about
trying to find out whether or not a
particular name is on the list is using
something called a linear search
in a linear search we're going to start
off with the first item
and then we would go through each of the
different items one at a time in order
so um suppose we're looking for the name
henry
we would start off with mary say hey is
mary henry no it's not uh and then we go
down to the next time and say is anne
henry no it's not the item we're looking
for
is george henry that's not the item
we're looking for is henry henry oh yeah
that's the item we're looking for
therefore the item is in our list
now if we're looking for a name that's
not on actually on the list we
start off again by comparing to mary we
compare to ann we compared to george
we go through all the way through the
list we get to william we still haven't
found the name on the list because the
name is not on the list and then we
realize we're at the end of the list and
so we conclude because if we've gone all
the way through the list and we haven't
found a particular item
therefore this item is not on the list
at all
so one thing to be thinking about here
is how long does it take to find a
particular item on the list
so suppose we're looking for elizabeth
you can see like elizabeth is somewhere
in the middle of the list
suppose we're looking for mary mary's at
the start of the list so
we can find her pretty quick suppose
we're looking for melanie
melanie's not on the list so we need to
go all the way through the list so
basically we can consider a number of
different situations when we're talking
about
how fast an algorithm will run we can
think about what's the best case
so in case of linear search the best
case is
well it's the first time on the list
it's very very quick
to determine if mary is on this list we
just look at the first item it's mary
we're done
what's the worst case well the worst
case is in this particular algorithm is
the item is not on the list at all and
that means we need to compare all the
different items and then we finally get
to the end we're like
yeah we checked everything it's not on
here
and then we've got the average case
generally when we're talking about
algorithm analysis we're concerned with
what happens for large numbers of items
as i mentioned earlier
if you've got a small number of items
you can have a pretty poorly thought out
algorithm and still
get it to work um it's not very
efficient but as long as the numbers are
pretty small
it will still work it's when you start
getting larger and larger numbers of
items that it really becomes a problem
so suppose if i've got a list of a
thousand items it takes an
average of one minute to find an item on
the list
how long would it take on average to
find an item if we double the list size
to 2000
well i mean i think this is pretty clear
uh
if we double the size of the list from
1000 to 2000
we will double the amount of time on
average it's going to take so instead of
taking one minute on average it will
take two minutes
and in fact we can write a little
formula that looks like this average
time to find an item is equal to the
number of items divided by a thousand
times one minute but um it turns out
that our little formula here
is highly dependent upon the specific
computer because
if i have a faster computer i can find
an item on average faster than
uh one minute four thousand items and so
really if we want a more general formula
we would actually write it like this we
would say average time defined is equal
to
constant times the number of items where
that constant is going to vary depending
upon the particular type of computer
but i still know that uh this general
formula where i have
some given constant determined by the
speed of the computer
times the number of items so as the
number of items increases
the amount of time it's going to take me
will also increase
at a constant rate
okay so can we do a search that is
faster than linear search
yes if the list is ordered we can do
what's called a binary search how does a
binary search work
in a binary search what we're going to
do is we're going to take the list
and we're going to divide it in half and
we will determine
if the item that we're looking for is
in the upper half of the list or in the
lower half of the list
and this is similar to uh
this analogy is getting old but i have
previously asked students and they
continue to tell me they do understand
this analogy so i'm gonna continue using
it
so uh the analogy would be similar to if
you have a physical telephone book
um and you know you're trying to find
a name in that phone book you split the
phone book in half
and you say is the name in the first
half of the phone book or is in the last
half of the phone book oh it's in the
first half of the phone book okay i'm
going to split
that half the phone book in half so i'm
look at the uh now looking at quarter
sections
is it in the first quarter or is it in
the second quarter
oh it's in the first quarter i'm going
to split that in half and look at an
eighth
versus an eighth and so on and this is
the same way you would also look for a
word in a dictionary if you actually had
a physical dictionary
so let's look at how this might work for
our
monarchs of england i've reordered the
list because again
binary search requires that the items
are
are ordered okay so suppose we're
looking for edward what we're going to
do is we're going to split the list in
half
now it turns out in some cases um
we can't split the list evenly in half
uh and so in this case i'm going to
split the list in half and start with
henry i'm going to compare edward to
henry and see if you know maybe i split
the list in half this is like
i open up the telephone book and
it happens to be that uh the item i'm
looking for
is actually um
right there i split it in half and
there's the name i'm looking for
that happens to just exactly be on that
page so it is possible
uh to split the list in half and
actually the halfway point that's the
name we're looking for but in this case
it's not
and so what i can do here is i can say
is edward does the name edward if it
were actually on this list
does that come before henry or after
henry
and in this case since the list is
alphabetized i know that
e comes before h and therefore i toss
out all the items
from henry on onwards i'm not interested
in those
and i know i'm that if edward is on the
list it needs to be somewhere
in the first half of the list so
somewhere between ann and george so i go
ahead
and uh toss those items out and then i
split the list in half again
and again you know this list does not
split evenly so you need to have some
sort of rule
in terms of uh you know if the list
doesn't split evenly are you going to go
slightly lower you're going to go
slightly higher so i'm going to go
slightly higher and say
we're going to go ahead and look at
elizabeth is edward elizabeth no it's
not
if edward were on the list would uh
he become above elizabeth or below
elizabeth
well alphabetically they both start with
e
d comes for l and so that means i would
be in the first half of the list so i'm
going to go ahead and
toss out elizabeth uh onwards and i'm
just gonna focus on ann and edward and
of course
uh there's edward right there and so
we're done
so uh it seems pretty complicated but
actually it's uh it's going to turn out
this is much faster than
a linear search um
one of the reasons why this seems kind
of complicated and you may not be seeing
the benefits here is that
the benefits are really going to show up
as the list size increases so
you know if if we've got 10 000 items
the binary search is going to make a
huge difference if we've got
five items not so much it seems sort of
complicated
and you're going to be doing all these
comparisons and uh
you know it just may not seem like
you're getting a big benefit and we're
actually going to talk about that a
little bit later on
in terms of well if you have small
amounts of items
you know the algorithm that you're using
there are different things to think
about like is there a big startup costs
um and so these are different concerns
so keep in mind when we're talking about
analysis of algorithms we're generally
talking about
what happens when the numbers get really
large because when the numbers get
really large
that's when we can't actually you know
if we choose the wrong algorithm we
aren't actually able to
have a program that actually completes
in a reasonable amount of time so
you know maybe i can write the program
and run on the data set
and in three years it will finish
running well that's
not a reasonable amount of time that
program is pretty much useless
okay so uh buying your search is much
faster particularly as the number of
items increases
um the number of times we need to search
doesn't increase
linearly so we saw that with the linear
search you know if we
double the number of items in the linear
search the amount of time it's going to
take
to carry out the linear search doubles
if we
quintuple the amount of times uh you
know the number of items in the list
um for linear search the number of
amount of time it's going to take it's
going to quintuple
but what happens with the binary search
is it doesn't increase at that linear
rate because
we keep on splitting the list in half we
split the list in half we split the list
in half
and it turns out that uh binary search
actually increases the log
so you may recall that the way logs work
is they're basically determining
based on powers so if i have log 10
that's actually 1 log of 100 is 2
because 10 to the second power is 100
log of a thousand
is 3 because 10 to the third power is a
thousand and
log of 10 000 is 4
because if i take 10 to the fourth power
it's 10 000.
now in computer science and in
particular for binary search
in computer science in general we often
use powers of two
and then binary search we definitely use
powers of two because we are repeatedly
splitting the list in half and a half
and a half and a half
so i've gone ahead and written the logs
uh
base two here um and uh
we can write that it was a log with a
little lower
little subscript two there meaning that
we are using
uh base two numbers instead of base 10
numbers and this is also sometimes
written as
ln of n but
the main thing to note here is that uh
this is much faster
okay so we can write the formula for how
long it takes like this average time to
find is equal to constant times
log base 2 of the number of items and
again
if you actually work out log of base 2
of the number of items versus just the
number of items if you were to plot
two on a graph you would see that log of
the base two is much much better
um and again uh
i've got that constant there because we
are concerned with
um you know the particular computer
is going to vary in speed and so what i
want to know is
in general if i'm trying to compare this
algorithm to
another algorithm regardless of the
specific computer i'm using and how long
that computer
is going to take um that's where we go
ahead and put in that constant
so you know i don't know if i have a
fast computer or i have a slow computer
but i do know
that for uh binary search it's going to
increase based on the log of the number
of items that i'm using
okay so uh log base n
is actually pretty good speed
improvement can i
do better it actually turns out the
answer is yes
and when i first saw this when i was a
college student this blew my mind i
thought this was the greatest thing ever
and so we're going to use a technique
called hash tables
and hash tables depends on something
called a hash function which we'll take
a look at in a minute
so with the hash table we're going to do
is we're going to store all the
different items
that are going to be in our data set
in an array and we're going to give
instant access to any item in the array
so
you know we had to go through each of
the individual items using a linear
search
with the binary search let's put the
items in half check the upper versus the
lower half
split the items in half check the upper
half of the lower half
split the items in half uh and then if
we've got a large list that
it's going to be a lot of splits there
it's definitely going to be a lot for
the linear search
for the hash tables we're going to get
instant access you tell me what item you
want and i'll be like
that's exactly where the item is how do
we do this it's like magic it's amazing
all right so as i mentioned we're going
to use something called hash function
a hash function is going to create an
ordinal number from a more complex item
and so our example we're looking at
words in a table but
this technique can be used for other
types of data other than just words
okay so i'm going to use a simple hash
here this is not necessarily
there's a whole science and
mathematics to choosing proper hashes
and i'm not going to get into it um
and i have not studied any of this stuff
since i was your age like literally
[Music]
um 35 years ago
40 years ago it's been a long time okay
so
uh so we're going to use a simple hash
that's easy for everybody to understand
what we're going to do is we're going to
form our hash by adding all the oral
positions of the letters in the word
that we are going to place into our data
set
okay so suppose we have the word cat
c is the third letter a is the first
letter and t
is the 20th letter and so i'm going to
go ahead and form my hash by adding
those up
together i'm going to say 3 plus 1 plus
because third letter plus first letter
plus 20th letter
and add those two together i'm going to
say our hash
function gives us a 24.
now if we've actually got over 24 slots
then we're
good to go um but
if we don't have 24 slots uh we've got a
limited number of slots where
the hash function can come with larger
numbers than the actual number of
positions we have which is pretty common
i mean in fact in this case uh with cat
um you know you can you can make the
argument that well
uh you know i can i can have 26
characters so it'd be 26 plus 26 plus 26
but that only works if um all of our
words have
three letters so um anyway so it's
pretty common to have hash functions
come
with numbers that are much larger than
the size of the table that you're
starting the data in
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go ahead and perform a modulus
you may recall that modulus gives me the
integer remainder of dividing something
out
so i'm going to do is i'm going to take
the hash function
the value returned by the hash function
i'm going to modulus it
by the number of slots i have in my
table
and that's actually where i'm going to
go ahead and look up the item
so in this particular case suppose we
were storing these items in array which
has
10 slots um what we're going to do
is i'm going to go ahead and take cat
which gave me the 3 plus 1 plus 20 is 24
and i need that to fit between 0 and 9
and so i'm going to go ahead and take
the 24 and do
a modulus on 10 and so again modulus
gives me the integer remainder so this
is basically saying
take 24 divided by 10 that would give
you
2 if we were doing integer arithmetic
what's the remainder the remainder is
four so the modulus is four
and so i would go ahead and put cat in
the fourth slot in our
array here okay so we can do a bunch of
these so dog
uh d is the fourth letter o is the
fifteenth letter and g is the seventh
letter
and so i go ahead and add those all
together that gives me 26.
i take the modulus which gives me a six
so i would go ahead and
place captain slot four and dog and slot
six
tip uh and these are just three letter
words but you can use whatever length
word that you want
and that'll get you larger and larger
numbers potentially
but since we're always modulating by 10
it doesn't really matter we're always
going to end up with a number between
0 and 9 after we've completed that
modulus okay so
uh tip t is the 20th letter
i is the ninth letter and p is the 16th
letter that gives me 45
y just 10. i'm going to go ahead and put
that slot 5. now one thing that you may
be
thinking here is that
hey isn't it possible to end up with two
items in the same
slot absolutely it is so if i've got cat
that's 3 plus 1 plus 20 and i've got act
that's 1 plus 3 plus 20.
those both hash to the same location and
so this is called a collision
and it's a variety of different
techniques that can be used to handle
collisions
but we're not going to talk about them
in this class uh if you have a well
chosen hashing function
um and if you have a lot of slots
it's not a problem and it actually turns
out um i haven't studied this but uh
but if you study this it turns out that
you can have a surprisingly small hash
table and still be pretty efficient so
you might be thinking well if i've got
50 items and i have a hash table that's
a thousand items
big enough to store a thousand items and
i'm not going to have that many
collisions and that is certainly true
but it turns out you don't actually need
a table that that's all that
big in order to not have that many
collisions they're
kind of surprised by that result okay so
we've been talking about using the hash
to put items in the table
and then of course if you're trying to
figure out if an item is in the table as
opposed to putting an item
into the table you just do the same
thing so suppose
um i want to look up and see if box is
in our table well i go ahead and
calculate the hash
b is the second letter o is the 15th
letter and x is the 24th letter i add
them all up
that gives me 41. 41 minus 10 is one
and then i check if the item is in this
given location so i say hey
let's go ahead and check item one in our
table
is that box you know and if there's
nothing there
uh then i know that box is not in
the table if there's something else in
slot one
well that's the collision thing that we
just talked about a minute ago
and that has that definitely has some
fairly reasonable solutions but uh
they're a little complicated so we're
not going to describe them in this
lecture just be aware that
yes hashing functions can cause
collisions where two things hash the
same location
that's tully thing you know if you look
at this going
hey isn't there something i seem to
recall a joke about
dog and god uh won't that create
a hash clip you know hat same hash value
yes it will
and there are ways to handle it okay
um so how does hash tables compare with
linear search and binary search hash
tables are much much better
it's like i said it's like magic this
stuff's amazing
so with hash tables whether my table
contains 20 items
200 items 200 000 items it still takes
the exact same amount of time to
determine the items in the table
i just go ahead and look at the item
that i'm trying to look up i calculated
hash function
which does not change based on the
number of items that are in the table
right calculate
function you know it'll take longer if
the word's a little bit longer but
in terms of how many data items i have
it doesn't matter how many data items
i'm working
with i could have a million data items
it's still going to take the same amount
of time for me to
determine the hash for an individual
item and then i just
you know it's super easy once you have
the hash you just like go to a
particular item in the array that's
pretty much instantaneous so
this works super super well um i
again i i think it's pretty amazing i
was
amazed when i saw this when i was when i
was a college student
which again you know probably says quite
a bit about me
but i thought it was really really cool
i was like wow this is great
um anyway so if we want to write a
formula for how long it takes to find an
item in hash table here it is right here
the time to find is just a constant the
exact constant
varies again depending upon how fast or
slow our computer is
so in computer science we categorize
different algorithms and using what's
called o notation
so using o notation we'd say that linear
search is of n which essentially means
that the time it takes to carry out a
linear search
increases directly with n where n is the
number of items in the list
binary search is of log n which means
that the amount of time to carry out a
binary search increases with a logarithm
of n
and hash tables are of one which means
the amount of time to determine if an
item is in a hash table is constant and
does not change with n
let's take a look at the formal
definition of uh of n
so f of x is o of g of x
if there exists constant c and k such
that zero
is less than or equal to f of n is less
than or equal to c of g
of n where n is greater than k
so the f of x here is the actual
performance of our algorithm so
that would be for example how much time
it actually takes
to carry out a binary search and so
the g of x in the case of binary search
would be
log n so i would say the performance of
binary search
is o of log n because the actual
performance of
binary search that's the f x is
less than or equal to log of n times
some
constant for n is greater than or equal
to k let's take a look at this
c and k business here and see what's
going on there
okay so 0 is less than or equal to f of
n
is less than or equal to c of g of n
that's telling us that what we're
looking at here is
an upper limit so f of n is the actual
performance and g of n is the
performance that we're comparing it to
so we know that f of n is less than or
equal to c of g
of n and so if we're not able to find
the exact performance but we're able to
say hey
i know this works better than this other
algorithm i know this
does better than n squared or i know
this does better than n cubed
that's good enough for o notation
what about that c factor there why is it
c of g of n instead of just g
of n so that multiplier there that c
multiplier there
tells us that the amount of time it
takes to process an individual item is
not important so
you know maybe it takes uh 30 seconds
for one iteration of binary search and
it takes
one second for each iteration of linear
search and so
turns out that means that for small
numbers of n the linear search is going
to be faster but for
large numbers of n the binary search is
ultimately going to be much faster
let's take a look at how that might work
so
again assuming 30 seconds for an
iteration of binary search one second
for an iteration of linear search
it turns out that if we have 1025 items
and we take log to the base 2 of 1025
i get 10 approximately 10. so this means
that if i have
around 1025 items on average
i'm going to need to do 10 iterations of
our binary search if it takes
30 seconds for each iteration of our
binary search it's going to take 300
seconds
to process all 1025 items or to search
if i've got if i need to go to the 2025
items
in contrast i said you know linear
search only takes
one second per iteration but
if i have 1025 items i'm going to on
average need to do 500 comparisons and
that's going to take
500 seconds so what we're seeing here is
sure for small n that 30 seconds per
iteration on the binary search is going
to make a big difference
if i've got five items in the list and
it takes 30 seconds for iteration of
binary search if i only had to do single
iteration
i'm already in trouble but as n gets
larger and larger and larger
the fact that a single iteration takes a
lot more time is a lot less important
than the total number of iterations i
need to do so that's what that c
factor and they're saying it's saying i
don't care if it's a constant difference
in terms of
the amount of time per iteration i
really care about the the amount of
iterations all right what about that
uh n is greater than equal to k so what
that's talking about is startup time
so again it's possible for small numbers
of items that the
initial startup time is gonna to swamp
the actual time in order to process each
of the individual items so
let's say it takes a minute for our
binary search to get started
whereas the linear search starts
automatically maybe there's some setup
stuff i need to do for the binary search
i need to set up some data structures in
order to do the binary search
for small numbers of n
this could mean that the binary search
is not the right way to go but as my
numbers get larger and larger you know
if i'm processing a thousand items
does that one minute startup time make a
difference if i'm processing 10 000
items is that one minute of start make a
difference by processing a hundred
thousand items
at some point the better algorithm
the algorithm with the better o notation
is going to win out
over the algorithm that has a smaller
setup time but ends up having many many
more iterations
of uh processing that it needs to carry
out so that's the basic idea here
behind o notation so we're saying is
first of all we're saying that this is
the a
upper end on the performance that the
performance of our algorithm might
actually be better than the stated o
notation
uh we'll talk about that in a little bit
later there's some other related
notations that
tighten that up i'm saying that
it doesn't matter how long it takes on a
particular iteration
and i'm saying it doesn't matter how
much startup time there is
that ultimately for large numbers of
items
the o notation is going to to
the the type of o notation will
overwhelm
these other factors uh regardless of the
startup time regardless of the amount of
uh time in each iteration ultimately the
big winner is going to be the number of
iterations
and that's what o notation is measuring
okay so here are some common
authentications here uh along with their
names
of one is what we refer to as constant
so that's without like we say with the
hash table doesn't matter how many times
uh you know it doesn't matter how many
items i'm processing
uh it's always going to take the same
amount of time
of login that's logarithmic and we saw
that with our binary search
uh logarithmic is great great uh
no notations if you've got a algorithm
that works on o of login that's a good
algorithm
of n that's linear uh of
and log n um that's
okay it's going to kind of depend upon
the particular algorithm we're using so
if we're doing a sorting algorithm of n
log n that's pretty good
of n squared that's quadratic that's bad
and of 2 to the n that's exponential and
that's pretty much like you might as
well just give up that that's
not going to be able to finish in any
reasonable amount of time for any
reasonable amount of items
all right so let's take a look at some
related notations um
okay so we're using o notation or we've
been talking about oh notation that's
actually the most common way to talk
about these algorithms
and as we've seen oh notation says our
algorithm is equal to or better than the
given notation so if i say it's o of n
squared that means it's
it's no worse than n squared and it
might actually be a bit better than n
squared
there's also big omega notation
and that means our algorithm is equal to
or worse than a given formula
so you know if i say something is big
omega n
squared that means we know we aren't
better than n squared but
we actually might be worse and then
there's big theta notation which means
our algorithm is exactly equal to the
given form why do we have these
it's because when we're trying to
analyze a particular algorithm it's not
always
obvious exactly what the
big theta notation is but you know we
can often find either an upper bound or
a lower bound
also when we're talking about o notation
typically we're talking about
time but we could also be talking about
space
so usually i'm saying as the number of
items increases
how much time is this going to take to
process but i might actually be saying
as the number of items increases some
algorithms require some extra space
in addition to the space actually used
to store those items and so how does
that space complexity
increase and in fact we will find that
there's often a time space trade-off
where
i can process something quickly but it
requires a lot of space or i can
process something in a small amount of
space but it's going to take a lot more
time
merge sort is an example of something
where the time and space complexities
change and so merge sort actually has
pretty good
time complexity to sort all the items in
a list but it actually turns out in
contrast to most of the sorting
algorithms where we can go ahead and
sort the items
in their original location so it turns
out that merge sort
is going to need some additional space
in order to sort the individual items
so when considering whether or not to
use merge store you need to consider
both the amount of time it's going to
take and the fact that it is going to
require some extra space
and we should also be concerned with
average case
versus worst case performance
in general the most important thing to
be concerned with is average case
but if you start worrying about what the
worst case performance is this is useful
both you know if you want to make
absolutely sure that this
this performance doesn't start dropping
off well how's this going to perform in
the worst case
it also turns out that analyzing the
worst case performance can lead to some
tweaks
in the algorithm to avoid ever running
into that worst case
so probably one of the better examples
of
this is quick sort so quick start is on
average one of the best sorting
algorithms
that's out there on average just gets us
of m log n performance
however if the list is already sorted it
actually turns out that the performance
of
quickstart is actually much worse it
gives us of n squared performance
and so there's different games that
people play in order to ensure that the
list that quickstart is using is not in
fact already sorted and it
is sorted they kind of tweak the list
around a little bit to make it no longer
completely sorted
and that uh reverts quick start back to
uh
having close and login performance
all right that's it for our analysis of
algorithms
next we're going to take a look at what
are called undecidable problems
i'll talk to you soon